holiday shopping season is in full swing  today is cyber monday and online  retailers they are expecting a lot of  activity  because of the coronavirus foot traffic  its stores dropped more than half back  on black friday on the other hand adobe  analytics says internet shopping hit  9 billion dollars up nearly 22 percent  from 2019.  cyber monday today expected to break  records as well  sales could hit 12.7 billion dollars 35  percent higher than last year  shopping experts say people who are  buying holiday gifts just don't want to  wait too long  the reason being number one that item  might not exist in a couple of weeks  number two you might experience shipping  delays and number three  there could be inventory issues amazon  though says it is ready for the holidays  the company hired hundreds of thousands  of new workers this year  and is confident packages will get to  customers on time